and I was [__] them up for it [__]
started yeah hey do you uh these
condenser mics H these condensers right
yes so what's your favorite part of
condenser
mics oh them [__] pick up everything
you can hear everything like you hear
that in the back yeah yeah you think
maybe we should put a rest to the
funions no this is it I was making sure
I finish before we got started well
thank you mhm yeah that's nice no thanks
that's very considerate
yeah fingers look
weird
reach and
[Music]
touch
no Jimmy uh can you test your mic out
real quick yes how's that that's
beautiful I think you could be a little
louder yeah how's that check that's
better four so what do you guys think
about Austin comedy it's been crazy so
far it's a bunch of [__] weirdos yeah
like who like I [__] with you now like
Keith
Ray Keith Ray just an alcoholic he ain't
really weirdo he just it's a little
weird I'm want to say there's another
one like him in there's no one like
Keith that was buddy that uh bring you
upstairs to the the mothership actually
got me hype n he good people he G to
turn up though he got me hyped though he
got me hyped for the
show
tomato
yeah yeah my life
change for
real he's like the [__] Open Mic
Guardian Angel like the the guy that
does the death thing Hades like come on
over except instead of death it's Keith
not death yeah right it's life comedy
he's just like a shaman it's like when
you think of like a guy that inhabits
the mind of a comedian I think that's
that's him mhm I think that like the the
working comics and the open micers are
two different people but the open micers
if you just sit back and look it is some
crazy [__] going on in that [__]
yeah I went once it always be some nuts
like the whole scene no you know what I
mean yeah at a mic last week there was
two Comics fighting over the pen they
were like pulling the pen from each
other's
hands that one dude that get real drunk
I didn't know if he was homeless or he
was out there tonight older dude he got
like a low haircut uh white dude
sometimes he face tattoo no not a buty
name a oh yeah uh it's another dude but
he don't come around all the time I
don't know his name but that [__] get
drunk I'm talking about he max out
baby he be so drunk so do you want to
like name names so we can ruin his
career cuz I have a couple guesses I
don't want to like start guessing though
I don't know his name I I mean you'll
say if it's not that person so but no I
don't know but the name I don't think he
really like a a comic where he take it
that serious see or he just be5 type no
he I think he take it serious but a lot
of people don't really like they don't
have nobody tell them like hey that's a
[__] stupid idea don't do like that
joke sucks and then they keep doing it
yeah and then you know they them the
type that get mad and be like this
[__] audience sucks no you've been
doing that joke every day only people
laugh is for the wrong reasons yeah when
they be laughing for the wrong reason
yeah no like we not laughing with you we
laughing at you my boy yeah be so messed
up I don't know what it is I it's pretty
easy to tell when they're laughing at
you or not unless you're like super
delusional and you're like crazy there's
so many delusional people though doing
comedy yeah but uh you know what fun
about comedy is like sometimes the crowd
is so hyped like at the mothership and
it's so fun for the first two hours and
then they get tired and then they start
doing real comedy where it's like oh now
you have to actually be funny in a room
cuz they're they were already excited
and you just took them a little bit
higher but now they're down here and now
you can bring them all the way up here
so it's like more artistic that way yeah
I bet it's a two hour
show a long show at least let even
crazier if it's longer than two hours I
know like that the mic though that [__]
is serious especially if the beginning
like right at 7 o' you know they yeah
you see that dick get ate by three times
in a
row you see the whole room
sh it be scared to go up I can't wait a
couple said next yeah I'm
chilling yeah yeah the first two times I
did it it was just bomb after for bomb
after bomb after bomb after bomb for at
least like five or six and I'm like both
times why it's so hard is cuz they turn
those lights on and the audience is just
staring at you yeah yeah right it looked
different from the light maybe it's cuz
I don't know it looked different you
could it could look different it's a
real Club they turn off the lights red
lights on so you can sort of see them
but it makes them feel more hidden M but
I would like no lights I like to see
what that's like cuz sometimes I don't
like their faces yeah yeah like with the
reactions or you just don't like their
faces they're just like I'm going to
have a bad time tonight there's no one
and you can slightly make me smile and
that's the most I'm going to give you
tonight yeah oh yeah it's better just
hear the noise and like okay that was
positive it is a bummer like making eye
contact with someone that's just like
not having a good
time you always are dra to
it
yeah there's 200 faces out here but the
only people you see is this motherfu
when everyone's laughing they have to
smile they have to give it up they're
like okay that you did make the audience
laugh so that's why you always check in
with grumpy best they can do is just
smile smir that's the best way to
destroy a Heckler is get the audience to
laugh if you can get the audience to
laugh you can
destroy cuz you're playing the audience
as an instrument you can be louder than
Heckler exactly you can drown him out I
try to just like ignore heckler
do I try is easy who me I don't heck of
people I mean you have the energy of you
do laugh really loud sometimes if it's
funny
now awkward awkward silence like when
somebody
bombing it that is
funny man just be quiet CU I want see
better than any joke than I can ever
make cuz it's
happening you see what you're not
supposed to do you know I mean you're
like h see someone get hit in the nuts
with the football yeah that's funny
still funny
classic i' be trying to ignore hecklers
but I may be a couple that always get to
you you know what I mean that one that
happened to me recently I was trying to
ignore her but I was like bro I think
this lady is just funnier than me
tonight this is she got it she got it
she got
it me too like she got it was she a
comic was that the no no she just you
know one of them people who us just and
I was hosting too so I couldn't be mean
I was like you lucky true you know that
they got a show they do on Sundays I
don't know how often on Sundays they
gonna do it but it's a it's a uh a dog
collum like dude I we just saw that one
watch some of that it's a dog caller
second saw was a dog caller I was like
I'm not doing that dude I'm not doing
that I seen it it brought me so much joy
Jesus to see them people go but did you
go up yeah of course that why would I do
that that's Dem meaning I walked in and
Hooch was on stage yeah yeah and you
know I love Hooch yeah and I just
watched him getting shocked he's you
actually just see him he's the kind of
guy that would get a boner yeah he was
hard I think he's heading next week
there also it's hard to watch it I
couldn't do it the great part about
necessary they don't give it what I was
thinking that's even worse yeah they
don't give it to licensed or trained
they just give it to somebody in the
audience and say hey if they ain't fun
to hit it the one girl put that [__] on
50% Jesus this we doing this I've been
having a bad day
max
gonna that would be me if I all right
that sounds like something that you
would hear in like a report about a
foreign country like they make their
comedians
shock
shock fun like this is a great show I
did this is people's worst literal like
nightmare situation are like uh is there
a bucket or yeah right can I get 10
minutes
please yeah that's reason I would never
do that never watch me do it remember
there's one I watch it though there was
one uh show that I or like open mic
where they throw pingpong balls at you
and that got out out of hand almost
immediately it's just yeah if like they
suck you can just throw a ping pong ball
on stage and you know I was thinking
about this getting the outside venue and
get tomatoes Jesus but the tomatoes you
sell them for $5 yeah now if you got to
really suck if
somebody Lincoln but what's the
cat if if
catato violence they catch it yes
throw it back yeah hardest there's no
way there's no way that could go wrong
yeah that sounds like a perfect
plan you don't think this a good idea
you don't own a comedy club no I'm just
saying find an outside venue yeah right
people bu it they throw tomatoes at
Renaissance Fairs they do that where
someone like he people want more
violence and negativity in the world or
did they go to a comedy show to be
positive this ain't a com show this is
like execution this is It's a negative
thing it's like [__] wrestling
Coliseum are going to show up to that
you want to have a [__] wrestling like
I would check it out it's super popular
but what kind of clientele are you
getting to destroy your bathroom I think
there was [__] wrestling right what if
you're thinking like a business owner
you got to factor that in you want
people that are respectful to the art
form not people who are ready to destroy
things exactly all I yeah that's a good
point if I see [__] wrestling come
down my timeline all I'm looking for is
the date and time cuz that chicken is
Bal yeah go to a lot of [__] wrestling
events I think we been over over at
least been there you been there one time
I was doing a show at the Block and um
Beach yeah they do have midgets they
know they got like five rooms outside
they got a school bus the whole city of
Fort Walton Beach Florida out here you
just seen them little bitty [__]
jumping off of the top rope it was a
little ass ring that be about big as
this table
nice jumping off that like everything
was proportion you have it out there for
I forgot the Block it's a wild spot yeah
them people
come it is it's a lit room though in the
back I think they were just having
wrestling across the street from Creek
in the cave and I think there were
midgets there I'm pretty sure there was
it's you would go H you wouldn't go
wrestling you would if it was like there
I would like look inside and check her
out but you're like buying merch there
you're like bro I got in yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know the wrestlers you know
little Juanito and [__] yeah it's one
he he's a Ecuadorian you know the ones
with the face mask yeah yeah yeah
luchadors yeah
Luchador they got a little bit of Lucha
[__] you thought the country of
Ecuador was a
white rice yellow rice Ecuadorian
red races no I
know the
only one of those
ecuadorians no I'm actually from
Ecuador oh wow no uh what what do you
think about like Opera would you go to
an opera or would you rather go to
[__] wrestling [__] [__] wrest WR
[__] wrestling that ain't even a real
question I feel like it's people with
money at Opera I'm
saying [__] get a
mid got Opera
lady I get am I
be I don't know fre maybe
yeah probably like in a money money
money is also a
I guess that's easier
there what
we
good should we touch hands
yeah I'm left out what are you guys
talking
about about the Opera like in my we
popping
Bott in the Opera you get a section you
get sections I think
hit that not
[__] slow that bit down this
[__] say that [__] Elizabeth so uh do
you think a lot of black people go to
the Opera and like try to make it a
block party yeah Jimmy do you think that
oh I personally do but I'd like to hear
what you guys think no the people who go
to Opera like be wearing suits you think
you
think yeah we try to fit into white
people we're like yes Masters we will
enjoy what you do but cunning we are
planing y do what does this
mean oh wow that means respect and
honor what does this
mean that mean check
down first down
money money
baby thought it meant um Spirit trucker
same
thing you know I didn't I didn't catch
that at all yeah yeah I didn't catch
that all that would be crazy but what's
wrong with chugging Spears like isn't
that a good thing ain't that like
certain people who I wish I wish I knew
how to make a spere it just I [__] some
[__] up was it Indians who did that who
did they call SP I think that's oh [__]
yeah I'm sure everybody kind of came up
with
Spears to work a [__] spear a dis
Nobody by saying they a spear Che better
than a gun though they got Spears think
that's what happened bro they had guns
Spears are really cool I mean I don't
pick what's racist that's that's what I
read on the I think they were good at it
I they made that seem bad I don't know
how they did it but they did it like
that's that's like the joke with the
jigle boo [__] it's oh yeah it's a joke
like it don't it don't I can't get
offended like I don't know what that
it's kind of a sing songy word it's a
fun word it's fun but that's used to be
a racist word they're talking about what
is like how you can make mean anyways
spear
chucker I think [__] is like if you
like [__] niggering around like a
[__] kind of
yeah I mean but I ain't never heard
nobody just I ain't never say you
you know what I mean you know your
grandma be to c a lot of [__] [__] I'm
Haitian oh yeah y'all don't y'all don't
really know you didn't you weren't
around in the
1920s no they they just got over here
like in the 70s
H I got here like probably in like 93
when you think jig was around yeah my in
America like 93 yeah but like Grand I
think it's hell no they was like out
country for sure
when when do you think [__] was
[Music]
arounds 70s I was thinking
20s maybe like Honky Tonk
[__]
Google you can Google it but I don't
know how to smell it you fun Googling
[__] yeah that is true I feel like when
stuff was starting to get nice look at
them jigaboos doing good like I don't
know like dancing cuz they're too happy
yeah why people are like why can't we be
that happy we kind of free I feel like
but not really but like really during
the 70s you was trying to like fight for
rights and trying to like do your I feel
like maybe that man [__] got all [__]
up letting women think that's when [__]
got bad this guy
here once they was just like
hey women like shut the [__] up and like
go make me a sandwich then they started
being like hey you [__] ain't got to
make sandwiches yeah then the world went
this [__] right yeah that can't be a
coincidence you know what I mean no I
have no idea but I appreciate that you
uh have
conru I think women being free is a good
thing I think women being free means
they'll have sex with us more yeah they
liberated man way more SE I guess we
don't before more sex partners than they
did in the
60s back in the 60s crazy right now
somebody granddaddy had like two
different side families they wasn't
pulling out though you have to have a
whole family just to get late nowadays
we just [__] someone on Tinder or like
down at
unbelievable I seen you at the bar
tonight it's acceptable you're not going
to hell it's just like right still going
but back in the day it was like you're
Going H yeah oh we could burn and it's
cool like n you still going on going
hell nobody
nobody you don't believe you could
believe whatever you want but back in
the day everyone believed it so less
people were having sex no true true true
now in the 60s and 70s they were [__]
raw it was wild was ask like drug drugs
maybe maybe the 50s but nowadays we have
more sex and uh that's cool why were we
talking about that white people were
doing a lot of [__] in the S yeah I
feel [__] less than
ever stingy everybody's want to be in
would you rather try to get laid in the
50s or now now yeah it's
way B with a brick and be like yeah it's
me that's how
em a lot
less hey [__] woman and then she like
what do you want with me man that's talk
you talk to
me different time
why are we talking about this I think I
think we I think they probably I feel
like it just wasn't as more recorded bro
they didn't have like but now it's
recorded and we're doing it more you
think it's more or you think people
could do it like so easily bro you can
have a whole family like down the street
and no one would know a whole family
orend not true with the
internet you GNA [__] more now but
people know because you got theet try to
[__] you'll more the [__] yeah I think
so more alpha males now than back in the
50s they were all small too they were
like 56 yeah yeah [__] short
have you seen kid nowadays they're tall
as [__] yeah crazy it's like back in the
days like playing high school basketball
somebody was like six seven it was like
wow it was you a freak yeah now it's
like a team and it's four of them
[__] 6 seven you
know 11 years they're eating that
chicken
hormone McDonald or proba or probably
the goddamn [__] orange chicken that
they got out of Chinatown do you have to
make it about race all the time I'm just
saying you just said Fried Chicken where
are they McDonald you got McDonald's is
for
everyone but it is mainly a lower income
neighborhoods and it's like a food
desert and they can't eat anything else
and plus I think like McDonald's ain't
even that cheap no more yeah I don't
know what he talking about is not it no
more Jack in the Box is cheap Jack in
the Box is [__] F five for or that four
for four Jack in the Box make you fight
people yeah Jack in the Box yeah I ain't
never had that that [__] terrible is it
what I eat it though it's good they put
craft singles on their tacos hey we was
in
Houston that [__] made me so mad cheese
they just melt American cheese on the
top and then they char money saying like
I like I like the big Jack I like the
double Jack but that's like all well the
milkshake good yeah I like the sardo
Jack what are you talking about Jack in
the Box I never you talking about shitty
food I'm just letting you know like who
got the good what do you think about a
girl that goes to Wendy's I yeah that's
cool yeah that's good is that like thank
God no you a
blessing what what fast food would you
not date if a girl went there a lot like
White Castle I ain't never been there
Arby I think that's
faster got some things no I'm not saying
all the time just saying if she ate
Arby's all the time that's insane justu
all day yeah cuz
like [__] up the col's [__] She'll
always smell like beef yeah like me that
[__]
is yeah yeah I'm drunk Arby's that's
insane yeah that's like a missionary
that's like a Christian yeah would you
would do you eat Arby no you ever had it
yes yeah I mean I don't think that I
would make a decision like if I had an
option out of like Arby and wah I'mma go
wah wa every time but if it was only AR
I'mma eat
it I got I got one better Long John
Silvers she had to go to Long John long
joh but every day I go there every
day sauce what kind of sauce tartar she
she's doing the balsamic vinegar too on
it oh
that's yeah yeah or A&W though and I
have never even eaten
there yeah I have it's you know it's
just root beer it's just food root beer
sometimes you got to [__] some ugly you
Su what do you think I'm no I heard I
thought my phone you are paranoid dude
I'm not going to hurt you David Jolly I
would not be able to why are you afraid
of me no I'm just saying I know you know
karate no facts what press point
I what if I start reaching right now you
got a gun yeah I do for real what kind I
have one I have a little handgun for
real like one of the little cute ones
said it's in your shoe three bullets
pretty
good no you got like a Glock or yeah
yeah I like it I went shooting with it
but I mean I'm not good at it and I
wouldn't shoot it in a room I don't know
how people murder people it's so [__]
loud you're not going to be able to hear
it's loud as [__] like huh yeah that's
how you know who the murderers are if
they can't hear just ringing in a room
with no hearing protection
good is loud as [__] when you go
shooting you godamn even small ones
people people like don't get mad enough
here to murder like it ain't a lot of
murders in Austin so that's a good thing
yeah you should be murdering people it
was pretty nice like nice though really
shouldn't be other big city s every day
is like oops there's a [__] pops off
well you know murders are highest in
like Mississippi Alabama and like right
Louisiana yeah it's like black over
there I mean not like not racially just
like the graph that I saw no but most of
it is
like black and white that it's like
purple orange black I don't know about
all that black was the worst it's the
highest murderer it's crazy off of
Statistics yes statistics aren't real I
stats class I took stats class you you
could force demographics like in this
you could
for I'm just why wouldn't you if you
want to paint a picture why would that
not make sense who has the most murders
numbers don't lie got most
murders no they don't humans lie numbers
lie the numbers don't lie they don't if
you understand numbers that's the
problem you just be like they don't make
sense let's not think about it or
problem most people don't if you want so
you don't think the Mississippi murder
rate is highest or Louisiana I'm not
saying it's not but I'm just saying I
could paint that picture if I want to I
know but then you're not going to
believe anything you have to choose
Something to Believe In yeah Cho you got
to choose the I choose it's not black
people you're like hey let's not look at
statistics at all like that's not a good
mindset I didn't say that I'm just
saying that's how you become a flat
earther when you
learn you're a flat earther [__] we need
good public educ you think it's a
circle I think statistics is important
and I think like just mean like it
doesn't work or whatever is like I
didn't say it didn't work I just said
cater it to what you want to to
cater yeah you you can but you got to
like look at the context clues and oh
like Mississippi the education isn't
good either they don't have a lot of
money in their government they have a
lot of poverty oh the murder rate is
high oh that makes sense like you can
like work in context clues this is a
very valid point yeah yeah you can do
that yeah yeah you can it's a very valid
point no that's valid that is true I was
just saying it could be I I didn't think
you was about to like pull out real uh
like a real conversation you know what
the number of black people is
what
chicken sod y'all been trying to take us
out for 100 years H sorry about that
up with orange chicken we love that [__]
with L man with shrimp fried rice I know
what's going you don't like wait the
orange chickens with rice though right I
like you like it with L I get M with L
man no man rice is R is where it's at
what's your national
Indian which uh India oh the big
continent the other Asians
technically you're Asia
right you're Asia I mean a lot of people
say I look Mexican so I think I'm making
stuff up at this point it's common you
mix with Mexican
no what you
do you say no like a speak you speak uh
Pito like restaurant Spanish that's
about speak Asian oh Hindi Hindi no I
don't speak Hindi I know some words Pony
that means water like my boy my boy K
squizzy is uh oh he is he he told me one
of them what's a what's a what's a type
of Indian that's all is so he
no guess CU it's like different parts of
uh South
Indians
Indians son son oh yeah I think those
are religious those are oh that's okay
yeah what about Sundar was he a syabar
Muslim man that what is a what's a synar
or a
Gujarati yeah that's one you just making
[__] no noi oh that's the real yeah
what's Punjabi Punjab that's okay yeah
Bali that's a different type different V
uh own I think it's own I think it's own
country I'm so bad at this and I'm I'm
pretty high so what part of I think it's
like a state what's your favorite kind
of
indiia probably the Native Americans
they had such a cool culture of like you
know one with Earth we
destroyed B you
like nigas like D that
was whiskey
like was green so meanest finesse in
history that's
finess these blankets chicken
po these [__] bro crazy did 90% of
them died imagine 90% of people died
right now we'd be
[__]
were sleeping with cows and sheeps
getting all these
nasty the beautiful Native Americans
just prancing around scalping each other
it's crazy how they paint that story too
they'd be like oh everyone else was
Savages and they did the most Savage
[__] in history like that so that's with
numbers and ledgers yeah D that was some
nasty work it was called for and then
they did that to the Jews and Europe
like holy [__] we're really good at this
we should stop I mean leopard King
leopard went crazy with like African too
so that like it was just a
lot I mean I'm sure it'll happen again
so oh statement something side some kind
of [__] big ass I hope not I mean
technically there's one going on right
now what Gaz yeah yeah yeah
what Gaza is a is is a that's not a
country is it honestly I don't know what
all I know is people are like
I don't even know what side is going on
but I know people killing
babies z uh so Israel trying to push
them all out and then the Goin are like
stop and then every now and then they do
a terrorist attack they did a pretty big
one recently and now Israel's like oh
now you did it boom boom boom boom boom
boom just push push push so Gaza beefing
with Israel too yeah I thought Israel
was beefing with Palestine they're the
same thing Gaza is the state Palestine
is the people and Country they've been
fighting forever
like why is the sky blue at this point
but they was like bombing Goa they were
[__] them boys up bad one yeah like
hos it's like a rebel it's like Rubble
yeah it's
insane man I don't be listening I be
like I like I like to like look at some
[__] like when somebody talk about it I
look into it a little bit and I'm like
now I can just make up whatever I want
to cuz like I never knew that Iraq and
Iran weren't the same country nice oh
you didn't I thought it was like cousins
right right next to each other like but
they always did [__] together
right gonna go get some cigarettes Down
Down Yonder in the corner Iraq and
Iran think a buddy
comedy might turning up they outside as
a group that's funny what's another
thing you don't
know [__] man I don't be KN like a lot
about like that [__] cuz it don't don't
you know yeah yeah it's not in your life
like yeah you don't need to [__] with
that against them no I'm with you not
yeah you got [__] going on it's [__]
up that that [__] but see people be
thinking about stuff that's going on in
the world and they get all really really
dedicated and engulfs whole controls
your emotions if something that I can't
change I wish the best for you it's a
smart move whatever I can do to help I
will but you about it every day you
think about internal Palestine and
Israel are you beefing D Jolly will one
day become the greatest standup comic of
all
time that's not that's not going to
happen come on I mean because of course
it's not going to hit him in the sense
of know who's the judge that but I'm
just saying like all I do is com D like
it's all I do like I check check on my
son hey you all right in college ain't
gonna be no Granddad okay cool you know
what I'm saying yeah and like old girl
get on my nerves so I answer the phone
for her every now and then and then ID
be like oh [__] I ain't [__] no [__]
let me call one of these I usually call
when I want to [__] where's the comedy
you haven't got the comedy yet then
you're I mean like other those the
things I do everything else is like soon
as I wake up that's why think about
politics oh I have no idea what's going
on in the world what's your favorite
thing to think about that'd be
interesting you talking politics on
stage since you're just like [__] in
your own bubble just like you should
talk about Palestine and Israel on stage
honestly see just cuz everybody else
kind of knows it and you're just like I
don't make some [__] up like what what
from what somebody told me like what you
heard like I know Palestine that ain't a
country that's a people right that's oh
that's a it's like an area that's trying
to be a country okay I'm not even I
might as well be you is a imaginary
concept right now but Palestinians are
the people see none of that make any
sense so it's like brown all these Brown
over here
be isra people aren Brown meico wasn't
like Jamaica never like even if you take
a Mexican out of Mexico they're still
Mexicans so they just took Palestine out
of Palestinians out of Palestine they're
still Palestinians yeah hey and it's all
World War II [__] originally it's just
whose side you are I don't I don't
really
care no [__] they're not my
[__] people
no that's not even close I'm Indian
yeah no I'm just saying okay so they're
Muslim yeah that's true yeah they are
that is true I am Hindu which is but but
they're Muslim Indians look alike like
people in the Middle East and India like
to and Mexico yeah yeah yeah no no not
Mexican a little bit I look Mexican I'm
Indian Mexicans look Chinese everything
like I just seen some Mexicans look
Chinese too though look at Ty Rivera the
cat who you say with
the look Asian I thought he he he was
Asian sure sure I thought he was I you
know what I'm saying
like like I know nothing about that who
what's your who who you rooting for
palestin isn't it weird that nobody else
looks like black people why don't know
why I told you he a
racist but Indians and Mexicans look
alike but black people are very like you
don't find them anywhere else specific
they are only like real true Chinese
people I guess that's for most you don't
find white people out said of where they
you don't
find a true Chinese man I agree you got
the face of a true Chinese man or a
Japanese boy I'm or both well some
people like it I know I had a fantasy
like what's like a flat face what's the
lady name from what's the lady name from
Charlie
Angel Face oh
oh back in
day who is your favorite Asian lady that
you a bang uh that girl from Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon go Tiger Hidden
Dragon yeah you remember that CR that
was I feel like I remember the movie but
I flying with the sword that Jade
it's a good movie that's your favorite
one I don't know I I I got to think
about
this it wasn't a bad choice Lucy that's
who played in
um there so manyan girls in real life
but in the movie world there's like two
there's not
a think of any when you think of Asian
girls you think hot ones that exist
girls but they don't go into acting yeah
seen some fine ass asian girls but then
we take a little bit of Asian girl and
mix it with another race and it's just
like like a mid cuz they're so soft and
they have baby features and you babyy
any race you just make them more
childlike interesting just white person
little younger and softer and less
threatening
right don't you think Asians are less
threatening well Asians are Asians
Asians are
harmless teddy
bears but our faces our faces thought
adorable that's why Asian babies are the
cutest you watch they are assassins what
do you watch I'm saying Asian babies are
adorable whenever you go babies are
adorable unless you had an ugly baby
he's just saying they're baby assassins
that's all he's saying black people
black babies are so pretty whenever you
go into a a gas station have such young
features oh my God you can and it's a
Chinese man behind the r yeah and he got
them ballerina shoes on that [__] know
K Welcome to My t- Wing CH
boy don't [__] with man that's crazy
ready to die by that gas
St do you think the perception of Asians
is generally positive like we're we're
generally not harmful creatures you guys
painted that picture very well as a
people yes thank you if you just being
realistic y'all painted that so well as
a people we
PR bro everybody but Africa had a PR
Team bro like it was like bro these
people are crazy and the whole world was
like they are let's just put them in
doing good huh Indian people we're doing
okay we're doing good a PR team instead
of us bro not really
we you guys have your natural Middle
East no that's
not like a scientist or like a that's
very true someone who like you know what
I mean like a philosophical person like
a real PR person who should represent
black people someone like a like
philosophical person like or a scientist
or like a doctor it shouldn't be a
rapper orass Tyson no bro like who's not
who's like a famous scientist right now
that's black I don't even know
colonialism was a [__] what's
colonialism that's where white people
take all your [__] yeah or anyone Tak
yeah I was going to say anyone whatever
picture you want if you want I think
Africa had a lot of uh negative
historical things happened to it but I
think like the fact that uh there's a
lot of like talented people that are
African-American is like proof like oh
it's like everyone is equal you're just
[__] with painting a picture bro but
everyone respects like if you go to
another country and you say you're
African-American they're like oh my God
well they just want to see if you can
dancee if you could dance and then they
say that
word no the one you said I don't want
to so different doctor you dance like
our scientist yes like you're a good
dance yeah for you can break dance it's
pretty good it is good pretty
good
it ain't bad no you can
dance
what Play
Dancing Jimmy do it can you do both ways
yeah yeah I can do that going on here
you guys said that now we got to [__]
dance off
now oh he's been to a
rave I could see trying to [__] I we
just start pop pop
blocking up see that was
easy person dancing isn't dancing all
about your energy and yeah that is true
the vibe that you yeah the
vibe feel the vibe here's his little
drunk yeah that's g a [__] up to this
gummy what's your favorite way to seduce
a woman I put it up
pulling
out pull it
out Lou
CK I had TW I think he asked can I pull
it
out I a I ain't trying to [__] no
comedians though it's probably a good
one that part I mean but I don't know I
ain't got no opinion on that I wasn't
there with Louis oh it
was yeah but then they say he was like
hey if you don't mind like can I jerk
off
all she had to do is say well no I would
rather you not jerk off right here you
know if you if you don't give me an
answer what the [__] am I supposed to
think I don't know what happened I don't
know what happened so I don't even they
didn't say he raped it though right gu
that's prettytable though it's probably
uncomfortable like he just I think he
got way over oh he didn't he didn't rape
her at
all that definitely didn't happen
obviously I think I think I think what
might have happened was the girl thought
it was disrespectful like he didn't do
it in like a in a classy way yeah oh so
he saying excuse
me excuse me
[Music]
ma'am talking to
is my pants are extremely hot right now
if you don't mind what J can I beat my
dick and you just got you would allow me
Madam I'm going to protrude in front of
you
I am going to whack my may I Beque thee
to Grant my seen upon the brow Two
Strokes not a th sorry I so what do you
think about uh aiz andari what happened
to him he's an Indian
guy to his me too yeah that one was a
little weirder that one was kind of
sloppy but he was like disrespectful
about
blob he yeah he got got he was getting
his dick sucked and then he stopped was
a sucking a dick he had a wi it was just
a yeah he wasn't a fan yeah it was just
like a bad Tinder di kind of force to
blowj job upon her I don't think so I
think she did it and then she like
regretted it or something like that I
don't know I thought the cons consensus
was that it was just like a non story
yeah just like he was just sort of like
not he was sort of like treating her
like a I do this every day type of girl
like oh you're not special to me and I I
don't think she liked that she wanted to
be special that could have been the case
for sure yeah I mean a charge yeah she
went to an article she went to a
newspaper she was a bit spiteful oh he
was funny though I don't know about the
charge thing but he he was cooking with
the specials was going crazy I thought
he was hilarious
he's very funny that boy was cooking I
he just disappeared to me I didn't even
know I mean he came out with some
specials had that special
where yeah yeah he had that special
where you can see the backstage area and
everyone was watching from backstage I
think he had one at the comedy seller or
something too it was like I haven't
watched this in a while what's the last
special you
watched but I don't even remember you
know why I don't though it's cuz like
when I watch something I hear that
comedian's voice and my head and I'll be
like I'm telling a joke like that
comedian would write so I'm like writing
for him in my head instead of writing
like myself so people are malleable
they're like sponges for me for me m
when I watch if you just copy so many
people that you can't be accused of
copying anyone because you meld it all
together in your head in a soup that
might be your best
bet or you can just develop your unique
personality yeah without outside
influence I I just don't like watching
it because it stresses me out I'm always
like
am I good is he good yeah is this good
is that good and I just like H I want to
just I just I don't want to think about
it when I'm away from that's why I I
like to watch stand up live like I watch
it open Live watch but it's like when
you watching it on TV you start
dissecting it you know what I mean you
start breaking it down you can't sit
back just enjoy it as the art of comedy
and also we see so much comedy live yeah
that like I really don't really feel
like I'm ever in the mood to watch it
sit watch watch it on TV I can go to the
creek and yeah bomb for three minutes
know I mean but if it's like a big
special like Dave Chappelle I didn't
watch that oh yeah I saw that the gamer
one but I didn't laugh one time but it's
not but it's because we look different
now like we'll say that's a [__] joke
it's like watching that a lot it's like
watching a magician you know what I mean
you know what tricks he's
doing yeah the sense of laughing like if
should have done he should have said
[__] he should
have I would have Sue that
son I told him damn Dave you had a
stealing jokes that have
been you didn't come up with that
word Dave Chappelle is one of the greats
oh yeah oh for sure I just think he's
like really serious now it's like I
think this last one he wasn't this last
one he wasn't as like preachy as I felt
like he was some of his last
special like kind of having more fun he
real the dreamer one yeah that [__]
great stand up I felt like his last
couple though he kind of earned that
like when
I I'm saying could punch it up I'm
watching it and I'm did this like that's
[__] funny but when was the last time
you watched special and just
like I'll get a couple if I get a couple
Jim Jeffrey Sometimes some of his
stories just like the actual
art occasionally it's
rare get drunk sometimes and watch some
Ido on stage and he just says one genius
thing and you're like wow that was too
bad when I watch
com I watch live I still laugh like
hahaa yeah when I watch it live okay but
but when I watch special I don't laugh
like hahaa okay like even they open I go
to me a good open mic and get me a great
[__] laugh what's the last great
special that you saw that made you go ha
haa like throughout the whole thing I
have no yeah mine is probably like way
in the early days like Mitch Hedberg
sure oh probably
s he did snaping those when I went back
and watched delirious and raw CL I would
I I'll laugh at those the same way like
hahaa right now uh that was so fuing
yeah Louis CK chewed up I remember
laughing the entire yeah a couple of
those really bangers yeah that was a
killer one I like Greg Geraldo and then
also Bill more early but yeah like
killing
me what you doing baby S I got keys feed
Dam
Washington DC is a rough
place that he goes into the yeah the
house he's like this N word broke in and
hung up pictures of
himself sprinkle some crack on it bro he
that was a banger what was the name of
the one where he was like uh the
homeless D was jerking off what it's
worth I think when the great the great
with the purple drink yeah yeah this
ain't what
[__]
no he's
yeah's what you think about that Cat
Williams stuff that was pretty crazy I a
put one in one ounce of energy into it I
don't know nothing about it yeah well I
have so we can listen to you describe
what you don't know for 10 more
minutes that [__] that [__] ain't uh
it's just yeah I don't I don't I I
wouldn't be able to tell you about it
cuz I didn't take the time listen to
none of them like I didn't listen to I
like that that's interesting I been long
enough to I'm not like watching the
podcast but you just see things just you
know what I mean I'm on social media I
seen it I heard about it but like I
don't have an opinion on it cuz I ain't
put no in he really hates FAS on love
you can hear both sides it was just
crazy like I don't know I don't know
exactly what happened but no no saying
what he's saying is not true you're
going to see what you see on social
media would you would you wear a dress
like a special coming out excuse me
would you wear a dress or at this moment
today no okay so why do we have to be
gay we could be we could be dog catchers
why would we be wearing dresses of this
you know why I wouldn't wear dress cuz
you taking a role away from someone who
wants to wear a dress and rightfully
does so you shouldn't do that to anyone
you know what I'm saying no I'm not
saying so uh let them do those roles
instead of a regular
person that's a whole market right there
come on man you this to the people who
want
to that what about you never never I
mean at this point in life I'm going say
I wouldn't wear a dress okay I mean it's
hard to say what like NE never is you
know calculate now I would say never
yeah yeah but I'm just saying
like if I had a daughter and she was
like Daddy yeah exactly I'm not even
saying for Hollywood or whatever but
like well no I ain't doing no crazy [__]
I'm just saying wa on J I was just going
to say you're not going to do like the
Nutty Professor where it was Eddie
Murphy and he was in the some classic
[__] that's what I'm saying there are
some even Big Mama's House was pretty
good I like
that Eddie Murphy a different type of
funny 100% nobody else that put a dress
on was funny as Eddie Murphy with a
dress on you would never alls to or most
of them yeah that's what I'm saying that
[__] [__] a that [__] a legend I
don't know Mrs D fires that was you're
right that was that was great too but
that [__] won no clumps and it went Big
Mama
bro good I think this delire is the
goat
n uh what it trans crossdresser no can
not make that movie today though you
can't do it just be even the
like yeah you know what I mean it' be a
whole different play the and nor too
[Music]
I don't think you would have to hide it
just be like I'm a lady now I'm going to
be yeah your house it wasn't about being
trans didn't he get back didn't he get
his family back yeah he just wanted to
be with his children that's not that
would Happ girl yeah no at the end they
still got divorced but he was like they
were cool and yeah they were cool they
were [__] and
stuff you that puss with attitude that's
pretty good yeah I wonder were [__]
pretty sure we'll never know
Eddie Murph killed himself were you in
America when that movie came out dude I
was born in America oh my bad I was born
in New Jersey not in Florida the ass end
of that was
racist what village were you born jokes
now I'm just [__] with you man you
know I love you H you're my partner you
made the most basic Asian broke just I'm
just ask if you over there what's your
uh what's your opinion on that movie
that you were talking about Eddie
Murphy
uh delirious
Classics that yeah he sold out like the
mo he got he still got like the most
number
of off his TI it's one of them things
where you know what's going to happen
and you still laugh like you never seen
it cuz it's just like like this is like
it was on point though sure it was fun
what do you think about Steve Martin
he's great see mine was a great I've
never seen his stand up I've seen him in
movies he was doing like I'm sick of
standup comedy jokes where he's
like playing with the audience and like
making fun of the way that they uh an
audience responds he was like doing cool
stuff back then he was telling like
stopped stand up almost immediately he
pretty much went to
movies i' seen that that did Eddie
Murphy I think that was the thing back
then yeah he did did a little longer
yeah he did two specials and then he
started doing just mood yeah I feel like
Steve Martin just got tired of doing
standup to seemed like I think that's
what he said in his book anyone read his
Bor he wasn't like he acted like he
conquered it if you become wrote it like
he conquered it the art of live
entertainment is done now yeah yeah I
can do
movies you know they T right who's that
Martin oh yeah that's the guy with the
white hair right yeah yeah yeah he he
touring with um it's another Steve Steve
uh another older guy named Steve that's
a comic old guy Martin Short or Martin
Short I think that might be his name
yeah Martin Short yeah Martin Short
that's his name so uh yeah I mean I
think uh Eddie Murphy was one of the
greats
I think also for sure um for
sure I like Martin too he was like a
kind of a Pioneer on Death Jam well was
a different kind of funny death Jam yeah
Ma bnie oh Bernie was funny
too that was ni I Ain a Bernie Brian
rean
yeah keep naming white people I know
that's what I was about to mention well
he's getting
fa black comic Bill b i know Bill b and
Lou and he's like Mitch Hedberg uh is he
like a black
comic think of a black
comic black
comedian are they any Asian comedians
but you the only Asian comedian an I are
there not the only one Amy Wong Amy Wong
Bobby
Lee Wang is Wang yeah Steve Burn is uh
Ronnie Chang really gota think of
black Dave you got cat you got that oh D
fan D fan Eric
Andre Andre black and white yeah I was
gonna say what is he he's black
though
so oh
he's the bigger black guy right yeah no
he's fine he's so fun that's South
Florida he from South Florida like West
Palm Beach and Sh that's uh that Jewish
money down there
that's that's
interesting Pat Williams is one of my
favorites cat you know Cat Williams is
mixed with
Asian yeah is he really yeah like a
quarter yeah Philipino yeah damn got so
much
attitude back to your thing with the
that's why you with the breeding with
Asians yeah just a little
drop didn't work on cat it didn't work
on somehow a double a double
down that supposed to make you a
delicate person being Asian
yeah yeah a little bit W because Asians
are more submissive and shy so he's got
like a quarter of it and now he's like
this huge personality karate is not shy
bro that junk is insane but on in
general
y each other this is like your statistic
thing again what like you don't think
there's General Trends in
races I feel
like once you could paint you can find
Chinese people who are not like that
though but in a in an area you probably
could like per capita there's going to
be more the Yakuza aren't friendly
that's what I'm
saying okay so you pick an Asian guy go
out there pick an Asian guy pick a black
guy put him in a room who do you think
is going to do more talking on average
Oh I thought you going say who's fight I
thought you were fighting them talking
the Asian guys going to be studying and
quiet and looking around the black man I
can't believe we in here no basically no
it's just GNA be David Jolly in you is
what you're saying stud this the
difference the Asian guy not gonna talk
because the Asian guy doesn't speak
English see we didn't talk about that so
what is he going to talk about you I
mean he going to look at like ain't
nobody here to talk to cuz I don't speak
English yeah so he's just going to do
this all
day that's just how they are over there
too yeah there's not a big culture of
talking to strangers they say hello how
are you yeah they do all the karate
movies I see they go
Hate by some of those app those bananas
yeah for my nature they talk to
like
start it'll be the greatest movie I'm
glad that was a good uh excuse to do
your Chinese voice thing you love doing
that love doing bad dubbing
act
just it just takes a
while it any movie when you can do that
it's gonna be a Kickass movie what mov
start like this and then it just
go
but you said you were going to kick my
ass hear the music so what's your
favorite type of
Comedy slapstick I like all of it what's
slapstick what is that I like on liners
oh I don't like I suck at those just
like funny just like like stupid David
Zucker is that his name the one that did
airplane and Naked Gun yeah Leslie
Leslie NE well that was a guy start that
was acting like slap sticky oh that's
slapstick that's what that would be call
slapstick I guess so it's just like
super
funny there Mr water what a lovely coat
you're wearing anyways yeah so
stupid white people it's funny yeah like
Steve Martin I was born to a large black
flam or something yeah the jerk The Jerk
yeah dude that one's really funny yeah
he's like clapping off
beat yeah
yeah remember that I remember like The
Three Amigos even vaguely I don't
remember that that was like oh The Three
Amigos they had some good ones yeah they
had my Dad loved that movie watch that
one a lot which one was the one you was
just talking about the jerk The Jerk The
Jerk yeah that was like by what the 70s
and stuff 80s might the 80s yeah
probably the
80s damn that was some good comedy man
and they didn't have to do podcast you
know what I mean yeah I
mean I wonder if Steve Martin had a
podcast that should be pretty he did a
master class you know what I'm talking
about the yeah which I didn't I didn't
take yeah I was going to take that class
that's crazy yeah but you know that's
kind of cool you would have took Master
Class yeah I would love to learn from
the greats just study their minds and
try to be like them as much as possible
so would you
take 500,000 well
no $100,000 or dinner with Joe
Rogan oh [__] that's a good question I
would take
$100,000 whoa so you don't think you
gonna learn nothing in that dinner
time learn from the
gra um what if I go to the
dinner and uh um what about
$5,000 or or dinner with Jo you just
said less I know I'm saying I want to
know okay got it got it got
it what I would do $5,000 dinner with
Joe Rogan for a dinner with Joe
Rogan I would kick his brain and you
know what I mean like it's GNA be
beneficial it's going to give you
vitamins and stuff it's going to be
[__] you know what I mean like he G
like you you know what I would be like
I'd be like you know I could take this
five or I could take this meeting with
Joe now and not earn it just because of
some random ass [__] stupid game or I
could work on myself and get better to a
point where I'm meet Joe Rogan naturally
and in a setting where he $50 so he said
[__] the question
$50 and outb Steakhouse gift
card you get a two for one deal you get
a two for one deal take a dinner with
Joe
Rogan and I would tell him that David
Jolly
is a
horrible horrible
person really should not be trusted in a
comedy scene I'm just asking $50 and $10
$10 go to $10 now so I reject the
premise
so where's your line $2
million well yeah million okay one
million my God million okay so
uh what do you think
about the whole thing going on right now
with the uh the election you know like
Trump Biden it's coming out 2024 in
November Indian buddy I like that Indian
guy he like talking about stuff and like
trying to be real I rather talk about
the root of the problem they got no
black folks going no but Indian people
kind of guy ramas Swami yeah the the
indan he just I don't believe a word
he's saying he's just saying the right
thing I think he yeah he probably is an
Indian president that would be pretty
good it' be ice or some [__] probably in
Great Britain they have an Indian guy it
would be good right two Indians in
charge of
everything yes yes get done exactly it's
gonna get
done yeah the whole world's going to run
like a
7-Eleven pretty efficient I gotta say
I'm just saying they they're open from 7
to 11 a long time you got I put forth my
7-Eleven plan
get bro around like 40 years too many
71s go out of business facts a lot of
broken down bathrooms in
America some shitty establishments they
over yeah it's reliable no nothing's
offensive about that and I don't own all
the s elens bro [__] yeah just own
like one [__] familyowned who would y
vote for I don't vote me I would vote
for Bernie Sanders nope yeah oh if he he
if he yeah never really makes it past uh
man you know who I'm I just think Joe
Biden you know who I'm rooting for
they're both too old you know who I'm
roting for my [__] Trump baby yeah we
running that [__] back I mean I don't
care nothing about you know I don't know
we heard your Palestine Israel opinion
so yeah yeah I'm sure them Palestine
Indians they've been tripping a long
time yeah yeah yeah jol's a drum
supporter you gotta cancel out his vote
you gota vote for Biden yeah he is funny
he was funny though
but I want to
see like the stand up comedian what they
they talking crazy in the comment yeah
they're saying uh isn't Punjab a
province in Northern India what is that
I thought that
was baby boomers Love Steve Martin he is
a good
actor he acted yeah that's what I'm
saying remember for his movies I never
even knew he did stand up he started as
a stand up yeah it's a lot of people I
didn't even know
started doing stand up first and then
they switch them movies back in a lot of
them boys started with stand up CU that
was like the only way to get on yeah
what you a different look like the
stereotypical like a fantasy what they
wanted like to paint the for the most
part in film at least yeah like Michael
Keaton was a stand up you know like that
say wasn't Tom Hanks even like first or
did he just play a standup no he just
played a stand up yeah they had a locker
room they're like in a comedy club all
the comedians get in a locker room and
CH it was so weird yeah what was that
hunch lines yeah they were in like Sally
Field and uh Tom Hanks were in this like
locker room changing into their show
clothes or some
[__] so dumb like it was a sports that
movie stun funny we need bring that back
I think we got start yeah stage clothes
and lockers you just can't act like a
funny standup comedian cuz like Tom
Hanks was in that movie doing stand up
you know but he just sucked it was so B
yeah they just added a laugh track well
I mean it was like acting so like they
were queued to laugh oh yeah yeah
because it was a
movie he suck he have no heat oh none I
me crazy uh it's like a really early
movie yeah but they [__] Tom h s
field rest in peace theide field
yeah be happy that reming movies or
she's alive I think of creativity no
she's like in her 70s what show that
they keep marel movies and like they got
a lack of creativity yeah I think we
don't know who we are as a species yeah
we like we conquer the world now we're
just getting useless Wars I think Iraq
really [__] us up
culturally you think so yeah so we're
like oh nobody's in charge what you mean
when they Dro those bombs on us no not
on us but like on on it Oh you mean
911 not
911 when do they drop bombs on us yeah
that's what I was trying to make no like
you mean we Dro bombs on them when we
were beefing with them boys in Iraq Ain
that who we fought you know we them boys
yeah we fought a lot of people here
though yeah I think America's been at
War for
like start
200 no just as like a a thing yeah I
mean we have an army the good thing
about an army is that you can get so
much [__] like you can invest $1 in an
army and they can get you like $20 worth
of gold so it's like right it's a
goodest that makes a lot of sense yeah
never looked at it like that CU all they
do is not even gonna lie to you all they
doing is taking [__] yeah yeah it's
ours pry cool when it's like a net
negative it's an inefficient way to do
it especially when every corner of the
world is already covered and just taking
from one side it's going to imbalance it
yeah it's not good about it what do you
think about uh the
Jews I love the Jew I love Jewish people
Jewish people are great great
individuals and great wonderful
human person that's what I got to say
about Jewish people great people they're
great I think they amazing human I like
them I got a lot of Jewish friends they
are great people H yeah you know what
I'm saying I'm a do you think about
Jewish people yeah I think that they are
have been like such a help to the white
people and white people really owe them
a lot because they were like helping
them with the banking [__] which is like
so crazy how you can [__] people up with
that
[__] yeah what you think about the
Jewish people yeah I think they great
with
money and very
sweet wish they would give you some
money maybe you know Jesus was a Jew and
Jesus is my Lord and Savior so so it's
kind of like I'm down with the Jews I
feel yeah I'm I'm kind of mid on them
I'm whatever I can take it or leave it
yeah no I said take your Le makes a lot
about a lot of stuff I think the Jews
are great you know like they figur I
mean like people figured out how to take
uh Investments they're like hey give us
money and then in the future you'll get
it back so you can use money from the
future now and you could fund these
giant boats that go out and then
hopefully find land and come back with a
lot of
booty right yeah that's a crazy I didn't
even think about yeah I didn't even know
like when you put it that way yeah you
can find a lot of stuff if you have the
money to do it Conquest crazy yeah
that's like world do that was literally
world
domination hey I'm about to start a
league we gonna order it off the
internet everybody gonna buy like a
different kind of costume then like
certain nights of the week when
everybody in town we going to all go
downtown dress like the costume and beat
up homeless
people like bum do that but after we
beat get knifed no after we beat him up
we GNA pick him up and like we gonna
clean them up get them together and like
we're going to film it have an
intervention with right there like just
talk to him like hey man we're just
[__] with you but yeah g to start the
relationship out on the right foot yeah
it's like Extreme Makeover but with
violence instead makeup
a good ass whipping to do I'll set you
straight a little bit yeah it'll set you
straight it'll traumatize you that's
true put you in SM around that that's
also true but for the week right after
it'll
be yeah you'll you'll
behave yeah what's the costume you
should just wear the costume every
single time so we can probably a clown
costume or something
f yeah little sad clown sad clown what's
your favorite kind of clown my favorite
type
uh I like a good scary clown like it
what about what about you Ro I like the
circus clowns ain't it that's like the
basic you
like make a
balloon what is this the
balloon that's they belong when I see
when I see a clown outside of a circus
that's when I'm like uhoh yeah that's
when they're up to no good usually
weirdo
yeah no f one of them got loose anytime
I see a clown in the in the in the
wild just addding about I ain't talking
to that
clown yeah that's a good that's a good
Mo it's a good move if you CL you Ain on
you on the damn clown over here talking
to no clown if I'm in McDonald's and
dude got a clown outfit on I am not
talking to you yeah does that freak you
out are there are there black clowns
it's like when a cat sees a
pickle
like yeah yeah so uh what do you what do
clowns represent to you some nonsense
just a complete divorce from reality not
the art of being a clown it's just that
when you breing breach that into reality
as to when it's like what the [__] is
going on you're taking reality not
seriously at all you're being goofy with
it and what are the rules in the
situation I could it that's great but
I'm just saying if I'm in McDonald's or
if I'm in Walmart you just see a clown
yeah you're gonna be like what the [__]
yeah bu I just I just don't so what if
you seriously a transgender that's like
a gender clown right the same thing I'm
just not say nothing to that person
nailed it exact Perfect Analogy Perfect
Analogy nothing against transgender I
just well that's how some people feel
they see gender they're like yeah that's
a clown look at that that's a boy CL
time most people like it depends you
know like most people when they see a
transgender they like what a ugly [__]
yeah you know what I mean like that's
ugly ass that [__] ugly as
[__] you have
do you have a natural do you have a
natural revulsion to ugly women when you
see like a particularly ugly woman
you're like oh my God this is like
making me think less like it hurts you
your psyche and soul CU you're like if
she real this ruins the idea of women
for me now no I don't ever Ru idea of
women but I'm just saying you tripping
now it just it's just
like I'mma still [__] you know what I
mean like she got a [__] on so is you
[__] a transgender person no that
[__] had a dick at one point I
mean I ain't saying nobody nothing or
whoever you want to date but at one
point that [__] had a [__]
shaft on
yeah you know what I'm saying a lot of
them still do yeah what if it's a gold
star trans person who's never had a
boner before yeah what what does that
even mean that's a new one I haven't
heard that one freshly used [__] it's
been from a baby it's been you know they
did the surgery and it's never had the
surge of hormones and boners Oh I
thought I feel like once you get that
first boner it changes you as a person
interest like so they got the baby at
like not attack don't say attack first
them there you got him at seven pounce
all right now
no they probably did get a bone yeah
it's it's a pre- boner dick that's not
good that's interesting I I assumed they
weren't C I thought they were just not
getting boners they're like trying their
hardest not to get a boner until they
got the like they're 14 years old and
just being like I think you get a boner
true now and again when you're young
like a kid yeah I think like yeah I
don't really remember like a lot I don't
NE I remember like flashes I was in one
of those people who remembered
everything from childhood like I think I
woke up and I was like woke up for real
and I was like five or some [__] do you
have any suppressed memories yeah I
think he got molested then n I'm just
[__] what the [__]
messing with you remember being a baby
uh flashes flashes flashes like yeah
yeah
I'm Touched by an Angel I did get
molested yeah it's
true yeah oh that's not funny that's
crazy for real no no no I don't it's
oppressed I guess if anything
yeah
yeah I remember being held by my mom and
my grandma do you really yeah that's my
first memory but now it's a memory of a
memory so I'm just like this is my first
memory and so I'm just remembering me
remembering that memory ever since time
you think of it it's another
memory memory of yeah I got to take it I
got to paint That's why like I should
learn how to paint so I can preserve my
brain it's good idea the the images of
my brain I can just flash it because
otherwise there's no way to get this out
I like how you're using two brushes too
there yeah paint when two brushes it was
flipping through
pain that's that Black Mirror episode
where they be like buy the memory so you
can like relive it you know what I mean
oh where they like you buying like
information you could visually like see
the like memory like replaying in your
like eye or some kind of like that it's
a good show yeah it was really good yeah
it was there are a lot of weird episodes
that were like oh you're just trying to
piece things together but the ones that
hit are great cuz cuz they're each like
separate movies mhm the British versions
were really good yeah and then the some
of the US versions yeah they were
trained you know one of my favorites was
USS Callister that's a great one where
the dude is like some psycho like game
program designer and he traps them in a
video game but they're not real people
and then these fake people kill the real
people yeah so I'm like sort of like
[__] you guys you're a video game yeah
and yeah it kind of ruins it cuz they
left the guy in the too right they like
left and became R over vacation that
one's good and then the one where uh old
people can be young again in like VR by
putting
in like chips into their brain was that
the video that wasn't the video game no
it was called like San chuper cherin no
something but that was one yeah I don't
know what season but it was good David
do you watch black miror
who black Mir are you tired do you need
to go home I'm tired as hell F can do it
baby let's go home Mir yeah what's Black
Mirror the movie on
Netflix serious it's like futuristic
like no I a never see it's on it still
come on it's uh it's on Netflix it's on
Netflix
season TV show yeah yeah yeah I need to
I I'll pay attention to it we can talk
about it next time I don't think you
should I don't think you should watch it
it's going to [__] with your head dud
what what what kind of [__] is it it's
just you're G to have opinions about
Palestine and Israel that are out of
this world yeah I'm about to just make
up some [__] about Palestine and Israel
so when a [__] ask me I have
something to say what you think about
pal saying this scripted thing like
paragraph yeah yeah
like [__]
Palestine know what that
is [__] just getting mad at me I don't
know no Palestinians I bet I know some
then [__] writing [__] on
rocks anything you want to say to the
people hey man shout out to the
[__] uh two Live Crew and the
freedom of speech uh catch me in the
city near u i be in San Diego this
Thursday can we talk about where we
going goingon to be at
Hol no don't talk about it you mind if I
tell the people yeah you I canot do it
no damn all
right where you gonna
be I'm G be H I'm G be in uh San
Diego uh January the 11 I'mma Be in Tim
Arizona at The Improv uh February 7th
and then just follow me at mrd Jolly I
got a lot more of this [__] you're going
to be at zany yep the 20th Chicago
you're going to be in yep Claremont San
die San
Diego I am gonna be in Louisville this
weekend Louisville hell yeah um I need
you guys want to uh play a game where uh
we just
like say something about uh where we're
going to be next week or something yeah
yeah
to get my
phone I think I'm in for I'm in Snappers
you're at Snappers might be soon I don't
know wow yeah yeah the one which one the
one close to Tampa yeah I think yeah the
Tampa one I think you yeah yeah I'm notl
to Tuesday tomorrow let's let's see who
has the worst city that they have to go
to I might be C I have to go like this
week I'm gonna be here is this my City's
coming back pretty sweet
I have to go to Greensboro North
Carolina that's gonna be
fun go to Buddha bu budha
budha where that is yeah yeah you know
it is yeah that's right up north it's
like a suburb
oh pretty sweet it's close it's a lot of
uh older people oh yeah yeah all right
they love you dude being Cass I think
I'm doing Kevin Dean
show Kevin in Florida yeah it's like a I
think it's like a Puerto Rican bar they
said I was they said I could pass for
Dominican so I was like all right I
guess
today I know black I
Dominican oh February 28th I'm at
ruins Dallas yeah nice it's a good show
yeah you're from Dallas yep I got some
some Dallas States just
uh just [__] play the game uh I mean
I got I got a roast battle that's the
January 18th Austin vers Dallas what's
up at hyenas and then 125 Dallas Fort
Worth Ro City and Tyler is
27th okay yeah you a good roast ain't
you I'm
okay no I'm [__] defeated plenty but
I got good jokes I just don't like doing
the five do roasting is like you got to
[__] play the audience it's not just
having the best jokes you gota like give
them what they want cuz they want you to
like look at them sometimes and
sometimes they don't want you to like
pay attention to them and sometimes when
they roast me I'll just go with it
instead of like fighting back which
sometimes works but a lot of times the
audience like wants a good rebuttal that
like hurts the other person yeah oh
right then in there yeah sometimes I'm
just like happy too yeah you go to you
know they're the ones I like them but
yeah it's stage time but yeah it's good
to have that like in your back pocket
when I'm doing standup where I could
just kind of flame a bit throw some [__]
at somebody if they're giving me [__]
you ever did the one of the Mother Ship
no I've done the creek and the cave one
and then a lot of the hyenas
ones anyways yeah I did a couple one of
them's
online oh roast yeah [__] roasts are
great to put online because you're not
burning any material yeah and people
love rast who did did you win yeah who
did you go against Matt
Boyd I have a roast I did for a guy
juble or
something um but yeah roast are hard man
like when I do roast I'm like [__] maybe
I should prepare like this for all my
shows because I'm
getting I'm getting paid way more to do
these standup shows and I'm not even
like writing anything for it this a show
like I'm doing 10 minutes
Max that's why I'll write if I have a
roast coming up I'll write roast jokes
to start it off just to get my brain
going because I'm the same way for some
reason when there's a roast I'm just
[__] going crazy cuz you're going to
be embarrassed if exactly you don't want
to lose yeah you know but uh yeah I
should be writing like that for all my
shows feel yeah that kind of enthus at
all I need to write way more you got to
start writing
start doing Bros get out of here start
doing let's
go sweet this is
doe there's no
outro